you
I've that means they can see us good
thing we put on clothes sexy clothes oh
my god man it is Thursday night ladies
and gentlemen look at us here in this
coming villany Cantina
that could only mean one thing well
that's when we go ah welcome to fat man
BR and I'm Kevin Smith mark barnard ah
it's a celebration [ __ ] because we're
here to talk about the Snider cut
Justice League Snider cut we were
talking about many things before we dive
it into any of it yes public service
announcement kids do you like mark
barnard in here guys do you like
listening to good ol Mark Barnard and
speak we all do mark Barnard and every
week you tune in to the show to hear him
talk about writing and being a good ass
writer and how right and good is good
for writers and stuff stuff like that
obviously I'm trying to find this thing
okay I this week just last weekend did
this thing for the hero initiative yeah
see where this is going
I do which was bliss the hero initiative
of course is an organization my friend
Jim McLaughlin if he didn't
single-handedly put it together helped
put it together I'm pretty sure he was
the guy the driving force the driving
force and the idea is you know the the
here initiative was set up for people
pros who work in the industry comic-book
industry who have perhaps fallen on
financially hard times or need some
bills paid or something like that Jim's
and this charity goes back it does had
in 15 years probably because there's no
pension for these guys who do this work
there's no union taking care of
cartoonists or writers or incres or
pencil errs and so when those guys get
old or retired or sick or whatever yeah
either they just have their savings
don't lean back on or they have nothing
to lean back on and so the here
initiative kind of steps in and helps to
ease some of those burdens I just read
your shirt profound the hero initiative
a wonderful organization that you know
is a way for fans who grew up with this
[ __ ] and and obviously it still matters
just we're still talking about it
in the case of me and Mark not only are
we fans of it like this is what we do on
Fatman beyond if we didn't have that we
wouldn't have a [ __ ] show and stuff
like that so like to give back to the
storytellers of our youth the people who
told us the stories that captured our
imagination made us become comic book
fans in the first place
hero initiative is a nice way to pay
those cats back so I did a a Q&A type
thing for zoom on Saturday and it was
the past hour I just passed where as me
and six or maybe seven people who would
like paid money donated money to the
hero initiative for like you know just
sit there within an hour and chitchat
whatnot it was fun as [ __ ] I you know I
enjoyed listen to myself speak and I had
a captive audience of people asking me
things about Kevin Smith my favorite
subject in the world so this I can't the
people who went and did it with me seem
to have a great time felt like it was
money well spent and money for a good
cause - the hero initiative I know a guy
do you know who's doing one of these
next spoilers we're doing the whole
thing Mark Bernardin's doing it next man
and you could go right now to hero
initiative dot org and you can sign up
to be a cue to have a QA and chat with
writer mark Barnard and man you could
talk to him about his entire career or
you just be like what's Kevin smell like
or I'll save your seventy-five bucks he
smells like weed and dreams but you
could have guessed that what a great
cause what a great guy how many slots we
got I think there's like two slots left
we're selling them tonight kids it's
happening right here during this show
because I promise you we got some show
for you tonight
and the least you can do is buy the last
two slots at marks table man come hang
out with me
yeah come hang out when are you doing it
Tuesday usually after
Memorial Day it's a good time and it's
kind of like this QA like that we do on
fat man beyond but it's just mark and
not me gone um I don't know Marco first
[Laughter]
so it's just like having a fat man be on
in your home with smarter less
irritating half of the show go to hero
initiatives org we'll be checking in
throughout the evening those seats
better go if you're watching the show
heavens think about some alone time with
them this is where mark takes you back
into the champagne room hey now
and you know what happens to the
champagne all the sex in the champagne I
almost lost that one you heard it here
first you're gonna have sex with mark
barnard
like a cam girl session but I'm your cam
girl virtually don't forget to tip them
okay
what's being a charities yes I got I got
another charity I want to talk about oh
my god
we've led with that one but we buried
the lead this is fascinating you know I
don't know what this sensation is very
often we're periodically I'm reading
something I'm like I know this guy Marg
created a brilliant charity and a
brilliant idea for Tom what it is it's
called the plague nurdle logs it is a
series of your favorite genre and nerd
actors doing monologues from your
favorite nerd movies and or TV shows so
it's people like Jonathan Frakes doing
the Captain Kirk eulogy from Star Trek
Wrath of Khan it's it's Tricia Helfer
doing the bill speech about Superman
from Kill Bill Vol - it's uh it's [ __ ]
my two other two favorites Phil Lamarr
as Samurai Jack a character voice yes
doing inigo montoya from Princess Bride
so not sounding like money hello hello
my name is Iman but he's doing in the
voices Samurai Jack brilliant which is
kind of great and the original Thanos
from The Avengers film phone and Damian
Portier was the dude who in the end of
Avengers it's DC I went to court death
he's a guy in a giant throne there was a
place later on by
by that Brolin kid but um but he I got
him to do the the Thanos endgame speech
so it's like the og Thanos getting to
finally close the book fat is [ __ ]
sweet it's pretty dope and he kills it
and it's it's a lot of that and the
whole thing is you go to the plague
neurologic calm you see a trailer for it
you click on a button any donation will
do it all the funds are going to
straight to the the no Kid Hungry
charity and all they do is they make
sure the children especially now get fed
children from lower-income places
children from you know in the middle of
the wild you just don't have whatever it
is it makes sure that people are fed at
a time when feeding people is harder
than ever and and then you get shunted
to a giant gallery page filled and
filled and filled with monologue I've
seen the page I could vouch for it it's
a it was a thing that I just I have a
bunch of actor friends who are currently
sitting at home not doing very much of
anything and all of them have expertise
in taping themselves for auditions ah
self tapes that self tape so it's like
hey could you do one of these for me and
so many people just raised a hand and
said yes I will that it's it's humbling
to say the least
and and and our man canvas decide he was
like I saw this thing man I'd I'll have
you know I too am a genre you're very
kind to say my man Kevin's decided Marx
you know I saw this thing on was variety
yeah and I texted it to Marga as a call
my god that's awesome Congrats
and then I he was like thanks it's fun
and then I was like you know some would
consider me a genre actor as well and he
goes I asked you I told you about it
last week at the bar you knew about this
I was like did I is that yeah and so
that was a particularly stony week it
was you might have to drive me I don't
know it didn't say good I was just like
wait this is you so yeah I'm gonna do
one as well which is carrying some
nobody's actor but the list who
collected the list I did you could buy
all their compiled the list the list is
life ladies and gentlemen that simple I
don't know how to say with this couple
so beautiful for that reason alone I'm
gonna shoot mine in black and white it
was a list of like every childhood and
adulthood memory of wonder from a movie
or TV show where you were like oh and
broken into heroes villain villains and
then like in the grey yeah it was
comprehensive so I looked through and
there was one there was Alfred speech
mm-hmm and Marc is like that'd be good
for you and I kept looking I found
something else I said no it's this so
what is perfect it's yeah I think I
honestly feel like I'm gonna rock it cuz
when I was doing it like rehearsing it
after like after I got off chatting with
Martin I was like oh I just wrote a
check I wonder if my ass can catch it
and I tried to do the monologue and it
made me cry while I was doing it so I
was like if I couldn't duplicate that on
camera I'm gonna blow out of Tricia
Helfer off the [ __ ] screen guys I bet
you she don't cry and her monologue you
know who does though who Rekha Sharma do
as what she's doing the member in V for
Vendetta when V gives that a letter from
the other woman who's in the other side
of the cell the notary her name is
everybody's name has to have a V and
it's all about how like she was you know
young and living in Berlin and like she
fell in love and she was a filmmaker and
I made these movies and then they took
me away they arrested me because I was
gay and it's just this it's a six minute
speech about like this very torrid love
affair that gets demolished by a
totalitarian regime that has no room for
the people who are different and and she
loses it like you get your seat in the
middle of it like tears and it's very up
close and it's it looks like she's in a
prison cell cuz she's I don't know where
she's living right now but sheltering in
place clearly but but ya know she cried
she cried
well the gauntlets been thrown down
what's her name Rika Charmin I'm coming
Rika coming for you my tears are coming
for you right
tomorrow night you heard him she's like
mark why are you helping
come for me that would a brilliant idea
how awesome and how so how does charity
is that you got to pay to get in that
site right you paid and what it like the
minimum is ten bucks you can pay as much
as you want but the floor is $10 and
then you can watch all of them you can
watch all them in perpetuity like as
they get updated like just keep visiting
and keep coming back keep watching who
built the website filling him in
Hannibal taboo that how awesome man yeah
it was you know I I had been sitting
here like I think many of us have like
how can I do something beyond write a
check or donate some money how can i how
can I use the the currency the coin of
the of my realm yes which is nerds and
nerd dumb and how can we all do
something together that might make a
difference and in like three days we
raise like five grand for no Kid Hungry
so thank you everybody who's donated
already and if you haven't you know give
a look give a look to the trailer you
know who else is in there Joe David
dismount chin Dave too small [ __ ] Dave
to smell chin my hero who does the the
Roy batty speech from Blade Runner tears
and rain time to die
really oh my god he's such a great actor
to reading his count Crowley I read the
first issue Evan really great book cool
it's great idea and he's gonna like
it'll translate incredibly well he's
smart he built a thing and now he could
go make a thing but it's all but it's
made by fan you could tell somebody
who's been like reading their whole
lives and stuff and very very good um
how awesome that he did one as well and
he was literally the first one that
showed up it was like hey I'd love to do
one what should I do and he looked at
the list I want to do that one and then
like a day later it was the first one I
got that's class second one Cameron cuff
get rid out of here man uh he was here
he was he stood on that wall you still
on that wall told us about Krypton and
the speech he does what does he do he
does jor-el from Superman the mice the
father great people cow really if only
you let them if only you trust them
that's gonna make me cry it's so good oh
my god give it up for mark what a great
idea man fun fun
that is so [ __ ] beautiful where can
they go give them the dress the plague
nerd alog calm or hit my Twitter it's
it's the pin tweet on the top so
first one you see when you get to the
site because you don't do him
alphabetically he does him an order of
importance people that shine Victor
Garber reading the I am God speech from
malice it is [ __ ] amazing he outdoes
Baldwin he really does that's a mark
funny I funny I I didn't know that you
knew mark Victor Garber and he said yeah
he's a buddy of mine and I said can you
reach out to him for me and Mark was
like please don't ask me to do that I
can't maybe compromise my integrity for
this alright man so that's [ __ ]
awesome
there's two ways to support charities
involving mark barnard this week look
how busy you are you know doing my best
man not content and have [ __ ]
hamburger charts and chicken chart
fights with your kid a fast-food
restaurant what what this one's better
as beautiful that's awesome and a geek
using his geek creds into bona fides
pulling other geeks for geeks to watch
something to raise money for real people
who aren't geeks maybe some art geeks we
don't I hope so hope they're young geeks
young geeks in training apparently we
have an agenda mark this money goes to
only geeks right to the geeks can you
quote for me the fear of litany so you
can have like he's got he has a good
heart but it's it's also a bad heart at
the same time he looks after his own
here we are in a moment of great
jubilation and triumph across the
internet happiness throughout the land
ladies and gentlemen in this dark time
of quarantine and covet EGH
Korona nonsense and whatnot and when I
said nonsense I don't mean it's fake I
mean like [ __ ] all the nonsense we
have to deal with a little good news
popped up one of those stories where
you're like holy crap is it true and it
was true this week or was it the other
day the other morning it was Tuesday
Tuesday morning yeah
time - it was like 8 a.m. or 9 a.m. in
the morning Zack Snyder director of Man
of Steel director of many movies but for
the DC Universe the Man of Steel Batman
V Superman and for a long time Justice
League and he is the credited director
on Justice League right like yes his
names on me we all know why am i burning
the lead and retelling this as if like
people are watching this a hundred years
in the future what happened we all know
what happened explain to me how 2020
works exactly it was weird
[Laughter]
we finally figured out we were in a
simulation Zack announced during live
screening a live-tweeting screening or a
live watch alone screening streaming
screen live streaming screen you know
whatever all those words that mean he
watched a movie and everyone watched it
with him online over that one service he
loves to death zero I think so which i
think is run by like a Russian really I
know it's like a bunch of Russians I
know it's kind of dodgy but it's but
dodgy the way that like avi arad was a
little dodgy fair enough probably
slandering people somewhere I'll be rods
like why you even bringing me up in Zack
Snyder's he's the one you should kill
now if Mark don't make it to the end of
show if you see a red dot it is for head
know what I'm just gonna keep talking
like nothing happened anyway we're very
happy moving on the Snyder cut released
the Snyder cut was a hashtag online for
what felt like a millennium at least two
years
was it really yeah it started almost
let's see according according to my
research Justice League opened on
November 17th of 2017 and like a week
after the release there was already a
change.org petition for Warner Brothers
to release Snyder's version that had
already had a hundred thousand
signatures Wow so the the the sort of
fan movement that had been sort of
rallied under the release the Snyder cut
banner has been going strong for a
couple of years so much so that they
was a billboard or skywriter at San
Diego comic-con at a Time Square
billboard Wow and they had a skywriter
at I'm not sure which con it was but
definitely in the last couple of years
all of this we talked about it here on
the show many times
Jamie cat ears you know went to a test
screening one time she filled this in on
a bunch of [ __ ] that she saw that wasn't
in the movie we talked about the cats
that I met on the set of Rises Scott
Walker who worked on Justice League both
versions and special effects team who
described a bunch of scenes and said
like hey man it was epic and stuff and
what you got was not whatever so we've
been talking about it for years but
there's been a mobilization of people
online I mean somebody had to pay for a
billboard that [ __ ] is not [ __ ] free
it's like $40,000 a month minimum and
Times Square
probably way more than that yeah that's
my guess some people you know would be
like it's all for naught this is never
gonna happen in blah blah blah and we
talked about like you know the there is
not a cut that like one would think of
you could pop up online that somebody
could watch somebody described it in a
story as a it was like a car with no
panels or windows or body right you
could tell what it's intended to be like
oh yes this will be a car right but it
recognizably as a car but you couldn't
tell what make would model whether it
had you know meaning tons of
green-screen tons of like unfinished
effects and whatnot and then also from
the story that came out I think in borås
KITT story in the hollow reporter today
and Boris KITT like he was the one that
broke the story about exact stepping
away or what we were told was AK
stepping away from Justice League
originally back in the day but in that
story
Zacks who says he's never seen the
theatrical release of Justice League
based on what he's heard from others and
had it described to him he said we have
only seen a core
of the movie that he made right so
that's saying a lot more of Justice
League was reshot then we were told at
the beginning at the beginning it was
like oh he's finishing up yeah I mean it
it definitely seemed from what I
remember like going back to the
reporting at the time like there was a
bunch of like vulture did a lot of deep
dives into what I think Abraham Reisman
was like onset or something like that
and like they brought jaws in to do a
considerable amount of work because I
think that time was that that you know
after Batman V Superman after super make
him out and the response of that and the
doughiness of that film you know and
then Zack screened I think what at the
time was something like a three and a
half or a four hour cut of what his
movie was going to be storyboards and
animatics and and what-have-you but this
is the version that I want and and when
it was apparently close to four hours
yeah close to where I was and Warner
Brothers wasn't happy with it at the
time and and they asked his act to make
some changes and then Zack had a dire
family emergency like you know which he
spoke about like it's not like we're
telling stories at a school lost a
daughter yeah he lost his daughter
person so like he had to circle his own
personal emotional wagons and his family
wagons and like listen I can't I can't
make this movie and deal with this
tragedy and I got to do what's right for
my family and so I'm gonna step back and
so that's when Warner Brothers went to
Joss and said hey here here's the
chassis that we have is the framework
that we have but here's some things we
want to be different and so Joss went
and reshot or additionally shock or door
you know contributed in some fashion to
what seems to be a vastly different film
but that's that be and the point is that
like the you know it's one thing to
finish a movie or one thing they had
some it sounds like it changed the movie
not just the tone of the movie the plot
of the movie where it was going I mean
we've seen Zack talk about like so I
don't think spoilers if you don't want
to know anything about this and what not
but he's poking about how Batman was
meant to die at the end of Justice
League so that's a vastly different
movie than the one we saw it was also
supposed to be the first of like a true
or no to harder with a dark side showing
up right and all these bits and pieces
that we pieced together over the years
and whatnot coalesced into he announced
during that man is still screening that
HBO Max is doing justice league that
what they're now calling Zack Snyder's
Justice League where they're giving him
the money to finish the movie something
now I'm not so we're not taking credit
obviously but we talked about this on
the show months ago going like HBO max
man that's what they should do go right
there and apparently I don't know when
we talked about it but in November
November of last year 2019 they reached
out to Zack and they were like Toby
Emmerich
I guess who's in Warner Bros and they
were like hey man there's a lot of
attention on this there's obviously
there's an audience for this they want
it so would you guys ever be interested
could you imagine being Zack Snyder and
getting that [ __ ] call where they're
like would you be interested like would
I damn here it is let's go I've been
waiting for this [ __ ] phone call
phone call he never thought he'd get man
finally got and now they're gonna do
Snider cut Justice League man right and
it's unclear if it's gonna be just the
full four hours as a feature film or if
they're gonna break it up into separate
chunks I hope they break it up into
chapters milk it like make it that whole
month and release one piece a week or
something like that yeah I mean there's
you know Zack had mentioned at least in
the piece that he had had ideas about
chapters of it and cliffhangers and you
know treating it a bit like a maxi
series unless there's a singular movie
but that's Fanta
I'm in are you kidding me like this to
me is best-case scenario best case
scenario they're in [ __ ] with this
movie and one did what it did but they
didn't it did and here we are but now
suddenly we're in this world where you
know you can see some [ __ ] that you
weren't ever gonna see like we're
getting to see a movie that was never
gonna see the light of day and like
fandom led the charge on it and if it
starts there where does it go do we
eventually you know get to see I saw you
know
release the air cut of Suicide Squad why
not like and in that case it's that was
less of a like it's an unfinished movie
they could probably put together he
probably has a cut on his avid somewhere
or whatever his system is and put
together another cut of that movie and
like put them up on HBO max like it's a
great driver for another I don't know if
you could trace a stream of revenue in
this way but if it's gonna pump
subscriptions which I have to imagine if
there were that many people to make that
much noise about release the Schneider
cut that's got to translate to a bunch
of subscriptions right like maybe I mean
it's unclear if it's unclear how many
people that is you know hundred thousand
signatures on that change.org after five
days is a decent number of people but
not enough to drive an audience to do
anything really you know like I remember
when when we first started getting comic
book movies for real right and it was
like man they gotta be true to the
comics cuz otherwise the comics audience
isn't gonna go see it and it's like you
think that they give a [ __ ] if the two
hundred thousand people who buy Batman
every week don't get a Batman they
recognize no they're more concerned
about the 50 million people who might go
see a Batman movie you know like oh I've
heard of him he said he's a man that's a
bat right you know like they would like
to have you but they don't need you to
be there it's true you know I felt that
for years and it's also unclear you know
just how much of the fandom this is if
this is an incredibly vocal minority or
if there's a bigger slice of the
demographics that's actually this is a
thing that we want here's the here's the
bottom line
this is probably the most attention that
HBO max has had since they announced HBO
max um or did they get more attention
for being like we got friends yeah you
know it's entirely possible that this is
the loudest that it's been but it's also
unclear if it's the loudest in our
particular world I Oh sphere oh my god
you're so smart that's true I always
like I'm biased cuz I'm like well I read
the news but that news is like
algorithms to what I read like it's
trending for you yeah yes you know I
figured that out like one day I saw
an article about Kevin Smith on comic
book calm and I was like I'm trending
and I wasn't told my wife and she's like
no not and I was like put in my and then
I looked and I was like oh it's news for
me
my app knows I like me you don't say
damn it yeah it seems like big news it
got covered everywhere and that's gotta
[ __ ] be good things for HBO max
for me as it creative is nice to see
like somebody get their movie back these
the Zack Snyder flicks I've not always
been like the biggest flag waver on but
I've always been a big flag waver on the
fact that like let him finish he's
telling a [ __ ] story like and when we
heard what Justice League could have
been I was like that sounded [ __ ]
dope man like I would love to [ __ ]
see that stuff so I'm just happy for him
because you know the dude had something
they kind of took it away from him well
he left or did he like that's my
question I mean I the story on the
record is right and we can only go by
what is on the record right he has said
which Warner Brothers is saying right is
in the wake of a devastating emotional
tragedy right his family he stepped away
from the film and then they brought in
somebody to finish what he started and
it's not at least that narrative is not
we took the movie from him it's he
couldn't do the job anymore
for reasons that are thoroughly
understandable and incredibly
sympathetic right but you know he was he
was emotionally compromised and like
couldn't be honest sent directing people
4:14 understandably and like totally
like and I get it but but I just think
the narrative of they stole it and they
they monkeyed with it is a little
disingenuous if that is the truth of
what happened if it's not the truth of
what happened which we have no way of
knowing
then why like here's the thing and again
this is reading between the lines I
don't know anything but why would he
have not seen it you know what I'm
saying like he has gone out of his way
to make it very clear that he has never
seen the Joss Whedon Justice League and
there's been
whew like kind of throwing shade moments
over the years so I you know I oh I got
the impression and maybe it's just me
that it wasn't all as amicable as all
that it might not have been but it like
I I was on the first season of a TV show
called alphas and I was I didn't come
back for the second season and that
decision was not entirely mine I've
never seen the second season like and I
don't think I ever will cuz it's like
some dudes kissing my wife all right
it's that feeling of like I remember I
did the pilot for Reaper and then I
didn't have any problem watching like
the second episode or that like the
first non pilot episode I was in my car
wasn't mine to begin with alphas what
you worked out for me but it wasn't mine
either getting create the show right but
it's also I can also understand that
there are a lot of emotions wrapped up
in Justice League for him and even
looking at that movie like when I got
fired from Playboy I didn't want to
drive by the building really is it was
very much like that's like where my
girlfriend lives and I don't want to go
by there it's weird because personal
just like it's you get shitty about it
I'm trying and I remember if I've ever
gotten fired from something and I cared
I mean like when I was a kid I would
care just cuz I was like oh [ __ ] I'm my
mom's gonna yell at me and she did why
did you get fired like your brother
never gets fired and but that was the
only reason like losing a job I wasn't
like oh man
that's interesting and yeah like I just
think that that there might be much more
to it than just it's not the movie that
I set out to make but it's also
completely tied in with this just dire
emotional devastation of which this is
an avatar then every time I see it
passing by it's like oh yeah that's the
time I had to walk away from the movie
because I lost my kid it's very true I
hadn't even I hadn't factored that
necessarily I was thinking like he was
just like I don't want to watch that
movie yeah
yeah could be that as well but yeah it
could be everything but he's heading
back into a thing he's heading back into
he's getting under the hood I I couldn't
be happier and for this kid man a kid
he's older than me he's always been such
a nice guy and stuff and again like you
know his
vision for the DCU is very got a demur
ah you know very big and very like
serious and epic and but I'm happy to
see him [ __ ] finish his song you know
what I'm saying like obviously it
[ __ ] means something to them how many
people can you say that about like
people who come in and you know make
flicks period let alone comic book
movies particularly back in the day we
you know now we grew up with Marvel
movies in this era but we grew up were
in superhero movie era where like people
didn't necessarily know what it was this
guy can I just put the skull on the
Punishers knife is that enough he
doesn't need a big skull on his chest
does he it's goofy so to have somebody
be so like no this is how I see these
characters and this is real and this is
like intense you know it's you don't see
that kind of commitment to material very
often and he carried a torch for it it
felt like for a while and now gets like
rewarded like he didn't seem to drive
any of this that's the one thing is
clear and if you're right about it being
like you know kind of way emotional for
him to dive into why would he even go
near it why would he entertain notions
of this sort of thing but I guess the
notions came more from the audience
right cuz fanbase started talking about
it and saying like release the Snyder
cut and he would throw out tidbits now
and then but you know he was never the
guy the conductor on the release the
Snyder cut train no no he wasn't at all
like it you know he he didn't he didn't
derail the Train not at all never wanted
to get in the way of the train you know
which i think is which i think is
admirable the the the part of this that
hold that thought oh yes let's let's we
have a continue our celebration
I'm gonna go I've stood next to you for
many years on the other hand but before
we get there ladies and gentlemen it is
a [ __ ] huge day for the Internet's
huge day for DC fans I know there's a
another way to look at this and we'll
talk about that later on and stuff but
you know as
as a show called fat man beyond like
where we talked about many times Punk
could be great to see that we are
getting to see it man
I am super curious to see I can't wait
and and you know just a while I was
buying HBO max anyway but like on top of
it like to know that this sounds so
[ __ ] corny cuz I'm not like I ain't
in the dudes League but to know a fellow
creative gets to complete their vision I
don't know there's something really
wonderful about that now there's all
sorts of mechanics to it like how much
is this gonna cost and they're saying
like twenty to thirty million bucks and
there's like actual photography that
needs to be done and zach has apparently
reached out to the entire cast to see if
they would be willing to come back and
and you know put on the costume I'm
hoping fingers crossed that Henry Cavill
still has a mustache yeah that they need
to CG off because the continuity wise
they got to keep it the same true my god
just for that alone think of all the
comparison memes that are gonna come out
of this I mean I want the mustache cut I
hope that part of this is that is the
mustache there you go release the
mustache I want the butthole cut it is
it's a very cool day for those who were
involved with the Zack Snyder DC
Universe and stuff which you know I read
an article I guess it was in of course
were skits piece where he talked about
like look man like Aquaman and Wonder
Woman inarguably came from Zack Snyder
and both went on to be billion-dollar
franchises you know so it's not like the
dudes not without a golden touch for
heaven sakes like you know he's it's he
makes big movies that make money a lot
300 and Man of Steel and what not even
Dawn of the Dead which these articles
reminded me he's working on army of the
Dead army of the Dead which is what a
Netflix thing and that's him returning
like to the genre that he had been at
that's where we first got to know him
yeah I mean he did commercials without
his feature debut was
the dead so is this you know good for
him man he's got like this ain't the
only thing but now this is a wonderful
thing that comes into his life and stuff
like that but I I look forward to that
when I was reading all the articles I
don't [ __ ] we're gonna see another Dawn
of the Dead movie with this game huge
news and so you know we've been having
guests here on the show on fat man
beyond the last few weeks and so I was
like maybe we could push the edge of the
envelope and see if we get another guest
and I reached out to someone who
definitely has feelings on the subject
of the Snider cut and Justice League and
whatnot and said hey man we do this
thing can you stream like around eight
o'clock and he was like that's when I
put my kid to bed and stuff can I send
you a greeting a video oh my god those
lovely
so we rarely pull it up we rarely get a
chance to do this ladies and gentlemen
but checking in from you know whoa what
looks like a very casual rooftop in
Gotham City I asked my good friend
Batman what he thought about all this
Snider cut Justice League stuff and he
couldn't be reached but he said Ben
Affleck in his place I just want to say
I'm sorry I couldn't make it on their
live but I'm very excited Zak's getting
a chance to finally see his vision
realized I think it's a great thing I'm
really excited for the fans to get to
see it and I wanna say thank you to the
fans because it was their enthusiasm and
their passion that made it happen
without fan support I don't think it
ever happened
and I love Zach and I love his version
of movie and I look forward to everyone
getting a chance to see it what up Smith
he is the bomb in phantoms yo how sweet
man Batman checking in giving his shout
out he stood by his man like from the
job he's in big zach supporter from the
gecko and how nice shouting out fandom
indeed recognizing that that's the
driver here like honestly don't happen
in these stories like that in the story
that Boris KITT wrote in the hollow
reporter Toby Emmert calls up Zack and
it's not like we felt bad you call him
up going like people are paying
attention to this this is there is real
the hype is real there's like people are
wanting this so would you so that was
driven by intense fan chatter like you
know fans brought this on and stuff like
that so where else can fandom take
things
what else can fandom change Marc uh well
in a world I mean in a world of canceled
culture this was nice like they didn't
cancel something they didn't cancel
something I mean welcome renewed they
cancelled Joss Whedon's version of it
yeah I saw that he was he took it kind
of hard yes not him he didn't take it
hard personally but I saw he was
trending I was like what happened and if
he was trending because people were like
sorry Josh yeah I mean I doubt he I mean
I don't know like do you think he cares
Avengers that doesn't it doesn't he
doesn't care and he you know we're still
part of the team that along with Zach
to be fair delivered a 700 million
dollar worldwide grossing movie like
it's not as if like it was it
underperformed
as far as people expected but it wasn't
like a catastrophic disaster either I
mean my my biggest concern if there is a
concern that I have and I do because you
know me is that after we heard from
Batman now we hear from Ra's al Ghul
over here
some men just want to watch the world
burn eco-terrorist tear it all down go
ahead I think the thing that that I've
come to learn about fandom being a fan
fan um in general is that sometimes most
times almost every time it's better if
we don't get what we want because that
is not what being a fan of things is
about it's not what being a consumer of
art is about we don't get to dictate the
art that we get we get to be the
receiver of the amount that we get and
even when there's something that we love
and we've devoted time and energy and
passion to we need to reserve the rights
to be surprised by it
and giving us what we want and what we
expect is never the path to being
surprised by things you know like I I
could have told you nine different ways
I thought endgame was going to end right
I would never have told you that
spoilers Tony Stark dying would have
been one of them right I never could
have told you that the portal sequence
would have been one of them and never
could have told you that cat picking up
meeow meeow meeow would have been one of
them those are all things that I didn't
know that I wanted that I got
[ __ ] huge Stan of kat dennings
over ever ready to whip out that um you
know I mean you you as a reader of Game
of Thrones would never have asked for
the red wedding but it's necessary like
it's a thing that you didn't want but
you didn't know that you needed okay and
I think that that fandom in anyway
getting to be behind the wheel of
something is somewhat dangerous and that
Studios to any degree beyond courting
the support but rather bowing to their
demands in a way feels that way lies
madness this to me I appreciate that but
this to me feels like is it that
different from Family Guy airs Family
Guy gets canceled Family Guy picks up an
audience on DVD Fox says hey let's do
Family Guy again and it comes back to
life this feels like that except nobody
has spent any more
I mean they spent money on a billboard
and [ __ ] but it's not like fandom put
down a bunch of bucks and then the
studio was like alright let's do it
again but close like people they heard
from the audience oh they want more of
this like we were we're we get so i mean
look let's be cold about it no
corporation is doing anything out of the
kindness of its [ __ ] heart you know
they're not like we want them to have
what they've never had you know they say
that but then the [ __ ] addendum is we
want them to have what they didn't have
for a price you know they want to be
able to sell it so is it any different
than you know when an audience saves a
show like when they [ __ ] send bags of
peanuts to whatever that show was called
or whatever the [ __ ] you know when when
when a voice fandom cries out it's it's
not the first time is what I'm saying
it's definitely the first time for a
very specific situation where it's like
fandoms now I'm gonna see a movie it
never got to see mm-hm
but fandom or let's just call it the
audience has always been a driver like
that's why they make sequels you know
cuz it's like well they like the thing
they'll like more of a thing or they
like it true but III do think that the
audience that is asking for this is not
the majority
it's the minority very vocal minority
and I don't know what the percentages of
that minority are I don't know if it's
10% of the people who went to go see
justice league I don't know if it's 4%
I know if it's 50% hmm but it's it's a
it's a certain few who are asking for
this and totally like if Warner Brothers
thinks for a second they can make a dime
off of this that will justify them
spending thirty million dollars to shoot
additional footage and do what seems to
be a vast amount of digital work on it
they think they can squeeze a red cent
out of it they'll do it and they
probably will even though they're not
quite selling it they're giving it to
you if you subscribe to HBO max of which
kind of selling kind of selling it
except I would bet that the
cross-section of this audience who's
been asking for it would have already
been signed up to age beyond max true so
how many new converts are you going to
get based on the Zack Snyder Justice
League but - the actual converts but
they can get
our profits proselytizers people out
there going HBO max man
articles go on HBO max they're stepping
up and doing this Snider cut like
Justice League Snider cut so it feels
like I mean I guess I would have I would
have felt a little bit better about it
there's nothing I feel bad about it
because again glad it's going to exist
I'm glad that the people who want to see
this are going to get to see it and it's
going to mean something to them I mean
I'm curious to see what actually you're
watching I'll watch it I'm curious to
see what was gonna be in there but I
would have felt way better about this if
it was Zack Snyder who've been calling
Warner Brothers for years saying I want
to do this I'm dick Donner I want to do
my Superman
- I'm that's true Dave this has happened
before
this is not the first directors cut in
the history of the world like we've seen
this a zillion times it's Francis Ford
Coppola saying I got out of the 100
minutes of Apocalypse Now let me do this
let me give you more Lord of the Rings
because we shot [ __ ] a year's worth
of footage that I have these movies
could be five hours long if you don't
mind the walking let me do all of this
and like I I don't have a problem with
that but that's a filmmaker who's
desperately trying to get this done and
by hook or by crook we'll get it done
this is hey Zack we're thinking about
doing this do you want to do it he's
like you know that's not a bad idea
you know which okay sure probably
because like here's a cat who in a
million years didn't dream like that
call would ever come you know and I'm
saying I know but like why and he can't
get your hopes up you can't lobby them
you know I mean I know in filmmaking
about knocking on every friggin door
possible and being told no a bunch of
times before you get to do the thing you
want to do that you're passionate about
doing as opposed to like hey how about
this and okay sure
yeah but in this case though you're
talking about he had that passion
knocked on every door and made a thing
but then thing got interrupted mm-hmm
and so now he does like he knocked on
those doors and then it was kind of
taken away but it's poetic beautiful
that [ __ ] life came knocking back and
said here [ __ ] second chance how
often you get a second chance in this
world yes rarely does one ever
now you know I'm glad for him if it's a
thing that he wants and he seems to want
he seems the one once presented with the
opportunity he's grabbed on to with both
hands and I get that you know I will
also say that like I had some of the
people behind the the release the
Schneider cut movement have not been the
coolest dudes almost entirely dudes to
other people on the internet you know
some of them have been awful to other
people on the internet who might be
brown or might be female or both you
know it the discourse got very very ugly
very very quickly and was somewhat
unrelenting you know to those who would
dare voice an opinion about whether or
not they liked Justice League or men of
steel or Oh being in their cats like
fighting about like I like that movie
people you're out of your mind
yes I don't like that movie really you
should get raped a lot like oh yeah a
lot you know obviously not you know so
like not appropriate not not up double
cool nerds if this is supposed to be
about a thing that you love desperately
does not mean that you have to be shitty
about it to the other side just you're
getting what you want and the the part
of me that that cringe is a little bit
is that part of that community doesn't
really they shouldn't get what they want
not if you're gonna be the shitty about
it how weird in a story about Justice
League you're worried about justice you
know fancy that it's a great day I feel
like for those of us who wanted to see
this flood great for Zach who wanted to
show us this flick it's a momentous day
it is it's cool thing man and honestly
like I never forget standing me on this
bar and I think Jamie was in that booth
so and she was gone like and then yeah
there was a dark side now is like what
what do you mean she's like they put up
a card in a drawing of dark sides and
dark so dark side goes here I'd watch
that now we're gonna get to watch that
yeah how awesome is that and I just like
to point out it's the first time that
Batman's been on Batman Beyond I know
but you got that
it was as we discovered your rolodex has
powers who knew all this time we could
have been having guests
big thanks to Ben for coming in and
shouting out fandom and stuff like that
and talk about the starter cut at all
how long before do you think that the
Disney decides to animate Colin
Trevorrow script for episode 9 oh I mean
well like if this does well yeah and how
do you gauge whether it does well or not
you know you know unclear what's the
metric what's the metric because it it's
probably not going to be subscribers
it's gonna end up being traffic and talk
and chatter but and traffic is always
proprietary among streaming service you
are absolutely right there's a world
where they can animate Colin trevorrose
episode 9 script like you know what if
project and like do you think that JJ
then gets shitty about that because like
I made up a so tonight like you hired me
to do this I did it it made a billion
dollars if I'm JJ and they're like we're
gonna do a cartoon version of what
episode and I might have been I'd be
like go ahead like that doesn't bother
me in the least I have got to imagine I
know him a little bit he doesn't seem
like kind of what no I'm sure he'd be
smart enough to be like look put my name
on it give me a percentage might be
great oh my god [ __ ] Star Wars
forever
yeah man who knows where this goes
Jersey girl Bernice released the the JLo
cut 30 extra minutes in Jersey girl yeah
man it's all sorts of sky's the limit at
this point but it happened with dick
Tanner's [ __ ] Superman ironically it
did years later like 30 years later he
gets elected listen I swear to God I got
this stuff let me do it let me give you
my version and they were cutting the new
DVD and I said [ __ ] yeah let's do that
that's crazy so there it is man I just I
just hope that it's not did you ever see
the Pearl Harbor director's cut there
was more of that yeah I saw it in
theaters and what was the director's cut
in other hours easy like I think it tops
out of like 350 my favorite [ __ ]
Affleck joke about Pearl Harbor
it was when he first got the script he
was like Michael Bay sent me a script
for poor Harbor and he had done
Armageddon with him and he's gone I
haven't read it yet but if it's Michael
script I'm pretty sure we win in the end
how's that extra hour yeah let's change
it yeah we bigger in the end yeah what
so there was you don't recommend
watching Pearl Harbor the I mean it's
hard to recommend you have to go cut but
yeah like there's there's some movies
don't need to be longer need to very
visit yeah obviously I'm the guy that
like I try to keep my [ __ ] as tight as
possible I always feel like everything I
do is an imposition to everybody anyway
so I just don't want to make it double
long and like oh my god not only did I
have to CEO Gosar's but it was [ __ ]
two and a half hours I kept in tight
that shows 78 minutes
ask you for an hour and a half oh I can
give you a lot more Wow so that was
you'd think that was like that would
that is that's a big news for the month
and that would be the only [ __ ] bad
news you'd have we can be done right now
like what the funny questions
JC yeah exactly but there's another bad
story
there really is and this is exciting for
us because we never get to talk about
Batman I'm Batman Beyond anymore big
Batwoman news what happened mark well we
go from more batman coming to one
Batwoman leaving oh yeah good nicely
done see yeah like a writer the batman
cometh the bat woman goeth away what
happened Ruby Rose the star of The CW's
bad woman which was renewed for a second
season on the CW okay Ruby Rose was like
ah no I'm leaving
so Ruby Rose with apparently the
blessing of the CW and Berlanti Co which
produces it she's departing the show
after the first season now and you know
even David Caruso when he left NYPD Blue
was a few seasons in right he like that
made him a star and was like I'm a
[ __ ] star and then I'm
bouncing now can you think of other
examples where they swapped out number
ones on the call number one I mean I
remember like the titular character yes
what was it called Kevin can wait
remember like M James had a show where
he had a different wife and then the
other like the next season came back she
oh she died and look who's back and it
was Leah Remini right and they tried to
recreate that dynamic so is can you
think of any time when I mean this has
happened before when number one the lead
on a show this would be I mean I know
it's an old reference but this would be
like Robin Williams being like I don't
want to be Mork yeah [ __ ] this after one
season when the whole world was like
you're Mork we buy it we're on board and
[ __ ] exactly yeah
I'm not from work the the most recent
example and it's it's technically
qualifies is the Roseanne Reid
generation we're like to choose on
another season we're on the Call Sheet
then like you know what Roseanne you're
not coming back anymore because
apparently you're an awful human being I
remember that story that was kind of her
like you know she did that oh well yeah
she liked some purpose yeah but she did
it to herself but not destructive Ruby
Rose is just like no I'm done yeah like
there was there was a piece of TV line
Michael Ausiello was was reporting it
just give us a little pat on the back
tonight we had referenced three writers
of the Articles that we steal from never
does that most on the show we never
really cite but three times we've
referenced who releases but yeah he did
a little digging and apparently the
consensus was you know people like kind
of like the name didn't want to be on
the record because I'm sure they want to
keep their jobs I said that it was a bit
of a mutual decision is that ruby was
the demands of being the number one on
the call she the star of a TV show are
high and she was a feature film actress
who had done orange is the new black but
she was a recurring guest star you know
if you were there every day if every
scene pretty much involves you if every
day you got to be on set and doing
stunts and learning pages of lines and
like it's a lot of work it's hard work
it's the work that I mean not that I've
like it is as if I've done it yeah but I
saw somebody do it Melissa does it every
week on mm-hmm
super girl and she's like Melissa
Benoist so like good hearted about it
but literally works every [ __ ] day
and usually every scene because when
you're the titular character when you're
super girl when you're flash when you're
a bat woman when you're arrow you are
there you're the main main character so
you're in almost every [ __ ] shoot
schedule every damn day and most of the
day of every damn day and you're talking
about shows but alike all right put a
harness on this person and yank him up
in the air and we got to do some CG
stuff and yeah you know wouldn't see is
hard and time-consuming anything on some
people out there I'm sure like I'll take
that job yes of course we would all love
to be the lead on a TV show but not Ruby
Rose apparently she found it like
grueling but I also wasn't there a bit
of like wasn't this a toxic fandom to
thing like I mean she got a lot of
blowback early on yeah because there was
a whole you know rumor that she wasn't
really gay and the LGBTQ community was
that right yeah although she dismantled
as soon as she was announced there was a
lot of like static about her being
announced as bad woman because the
characters because Kate came is comics
it was openly lesbian and and written as
such by Garrett by greg rucka and so
like and she got some flack because she
wasn't gay enough apparently
which she kind of dealt with head-on and
so there's that hanging over her head
she was injured I think at least more
than one remember that she almost like
killed her back yeah doing some you know
and there was a lot of rehab for that
and like it's it's it's a it's a lot for
any person to do if it's not a thing are
used to doing and you know it seems as
if she was like uh you know what guys
I'm sorry I mean I made a mistake
baby that I'm not cut out for this I
can't do any more and in what world does
the studio go like all right like
normally on these shows they got him for
six and lugger downs right lock him down
for a long time you know I mean the only
the only thing that I can think of is
that is that that desire for her to back
away
had somewhat colored her existence on
the set you know if the number one of
your call sheet if the star of your show
doesn't look they're happy to be there
that tends to permeate like it's a it is
the one time that trickle down actually
works and so if the crew is sensing that
the star doesn't want to be there then
they kind of don't want to be there and
then the writers are writing for a
character who's not giving it her all
and like there there seems to have been
a general like you know what maybe this
isn't the right fit for us
maybe we can if we recast which is what
they're doing they're not canceling the
show they're not killing the character
it's like no there's gonna be a new Kate
Cain in season two I fine I mean which
you know we've had many Batman's and
many James Bond's many Superman's so
obviously that will get used to that but
I find it strange that they're like yeah
we're gonna keep going like that seems
like an expensive show it is but you
know it it seems to be part of this
suite of superhero shows that they have
which all kind of feed each other and
you know they'll all go to Netflix or
probably more likely to HBO max and they
will all build there's a little
ecosystem where I mean it's the thing
that saved Riverdale like Riverdale was
not a huge hit first go on this is when
it went to net when it went to nestlings
and people got to just live in it and
binge it was about [ __ ] yeah alright
let's do more of this and then they
greenlit sabrinastrips was like will
take Sabrina yeah two seasons right off
the jump simply so that we can keep
people in this ecosystem of teenagers
fighting I don't know each other and or
ghosts usually their parents in some
ways you know their parents who might
have played D&D as kids and it's a whole
thing
well it's you know sad to see her go you
never want to see somebody be like I
don't want to do this anymore
but you know good for her if she wanted
to go and she got out yeah I mean I
think that the the thing rare very rare
that somebody's like no I don't want
this and you know I'm sure she gave it a
[ __ ] ton of thought because yeah she
knew the moment like she walks out
everyone's gonna be like what do you not
see you know she's got her own personal
truth to live with and apparently don't
involve putting on a rubber mask and
flipping around and throwing her back
out and stuff like that no until Marvel
comes calling yeah
oh yeah suddenly it's like my back's
great I feel good what do you eternal
put on a big-ass wig - all right well
that's there's some some exciting bat
news some deflating that means yes but
bat is the star and the bat goes on
indeed there will be more about woman
apparently and it's just not gonna have
Ruby Rose but still be the same
character so--but same character same
shell there was a there's a tweet that
I'm Stephanie Beatriz who from Brooklyn
nine-nine we're just like quickly reads
everything there is to know about all
right more bad news
are you [ __ ] me swear to god I have
more bad news it's a hat trick a bat
trick if you will thank you
copyright Batman Beyond a bat trick of
news ladies let's all take off our hats
and throw them on the ice okay all right
but sure it's a little faith it is and
it's also like I'm never taking my hat
off sick a [ __ ] you I'm glad you got
three goals but [ __ ] you this stays
right here you got to bring a backup hat
and they all do it everyone throws their
hats on the [ __ ] rink and then they
all wept no but that's how much these
people love their team mark we're like
they got three in a row one guy got
three in a row and they throw their hat
and they're fine to see it go get a
match go to charity or something what a
great question they all get swept up on
the ice and then they all go someplace
else could you give away dirty hats lost
a found is just this burgeoning like
bursting at the seams roomful of hats
and a bunch of people like that one's
mine sure
oh not happy about that trick anymore
Bill want your hat back um they do they
leave their hat anyway we have a bat
trick three Batman stories in a row did
you have that on your [ __ ] fat man be
on bingo code I'll bet you did bet you
didn't nobody's won that one yet what is
the third store the third story it's a
it is it is minor compared to the other
two stories still legit remembering we
had Ben Affleck on our show my know
everything is minor compared to benefit
show highlight so everyone tuned out
after that I I won't say that I didn't
notice that Ben didn't say hey to mark
Hey hey Smith I mean look I got a Smith
so I don't know regarding is hard to say
yes another guy mark is literally one
syllable but nevermind in order to help
fuel never enough for you it's always
something with you like I got a knock on
that door I don't want that to happen
Warner Brothers is beginning to think
about how to to re-energize the
theater-going market especially overseas
okay because you know kovat nineteen it
shut everything down almost everywhere
and so there's trying to prime people to
go back to the movies trying to give
them the irresistible the lure that they
can't you know turn away from and so
they are they've keyed up a rerelease of
Christopher Nolan's Dark Knight trilogy
that might bring some people out yeah in
Hong Kong and Taiwan in advance of
Tennant which still apparently is
opening in July worldwide come hell or
high water up yeah like Christopher
Nolan is convinced that did they just
drop a new trailer today they do tonight
in in fortnight if you're a fortnight
player you have to go into fortnight and
watch the new trail they just they did
that provides a Skywalker as well yeah I
mean I'd have to guess it will you know
do everybody who's not on fortnight will
see it tomorrow
yeah Jason Mewes must have watched it it
was in fortnight
alright so their idea of like you know
it'll get people come out a couple
movies they saw at home yep do you would
that make you go I love Chris Nolan's
Dark Knight trilogy but I'm happy to
watch it on my phone in the big house
yeah [ __ ] I don't even go to the big
screen anymore I put it on my damn phone
like if it was a normal sane universe
where it wouldn't kill me to go to the
movie theater yeah we're totally show up
for that you know what they got to do
they got a Snider cut that [ __ ] to get
me to go to the theater you got to put
in an extra half-hour 45 minutes if not
like 80% of a movie that I never saw be
if you put it is it all one long flick
minutes am I going with that
to be like [ __ ] if I didn't get kovin in
the first two hours of sitting here I'm
not going to get it in the next four but
yeah and it's it seems to be a bit of a
thing that they're trying to do like I
think they're also gonna do the Harry
Potter movies back into theaters to help
coax people out there pulling to the
library if that makes sense
to some degree I just that's not gonna
pull me in I give me the new new yeah I
want like you know like give me some
Black Widow
give me some tenets that allow me I'll
go off to the theaters for new don't go
out to see Tennant and I will
oh god yes really yeah and I'm not even
like and I respect the [ __ ] out of Chris
no I think he's a wonderful filmmaker
but I'm not like Nolan is God like where
you know I didn't go see was a space one
with [ __ ] interstellar I didn't see
that in a theater or anything like that
but this trailer looks phenomenal and
what was the last flick he did a war
movie oh yeah
Dunkirk Dunkirk Dunkirk was really good
i undid touches his gold although I
still haven't seen interstellar so I
can't say that yeah you tell you talked
about it I think I'd yeah I remember
liking interstellar until the very end
where it was like it's all about love
[ __ ] you [ __ ] you take this journey for
love where the aliens yeah unless it's
into the spider-verse and it's like
miles I know you're back there I just
want to let you know that you're gonna
be real special I gotta I see a real
spark in you just call me I love you
works about to cry good thing alright so
I yeah I could get I understand I mean
doesn't cost them anything put a couple
old movies in theaters my prime the pump
but oh no man I mean would end gain make
me go now I'd be scared honestly like if
I was like they're releasing that game I
was like oh I want to see that with a
theater full of people and then I'm like
wait do I want to see that hold on with
a theater full of people anymore in the
old days I did yeah something tells me
Warner Brothers is going to have to
blink off that July 17th date you think
I mean there will have to be something
that opens first right something will
have to open that money is good that
movies gonna make all the money it's
gonna make all the money or it'll make a
third of the money because they can't
let that money because New York and LA
are probably not gonna come out to do it
so then you're counting on the rest of
the country and the rest of the world
and the rest of the world is in various
stages of recovery and/or re collapsing
so like do you gamble a two hundred
fifty million dollar movie that there's
gonna be enough people to make it worth
it I mean look you got to reopen the
business sooner or later why not lead
with the best [ __ ] foot forward man
like I bet I bet my money on he's able
to get people out like he's the
modern-day Spielberg to some degree more
thinking Spielberg not safe Spielberg's
mindless but Spielberg's movies spiel
but I only say Spielberg because he's
now the go-to director reference mmm you
know what I'm saying like when people go
like well who are you some kind of Chris
Nolan like that and I'm like no no I
never said that him and Quentin are the
to go to director names yeah so he has
he has a shot he's got a shot I mean
he's to me he's like the modern-day and
way more fun Stanley Kubrick yeah I
agree with that
look there's an exacting nature to his
movies I don't know if way more fun well
I mean some former and then I'm like I
don't even know that's true not warmer
he's he's still a little antiseptic yeah
yeah but also like emotionally distant
yeah a little bit Spock ish about the
whole little spa Koosh but like they're
still what it's Bach say let's I'm
fascinating consummating captain
all right so yeah I mean look do it but
I don't know if that's gonna if that's
the thing that's gonna make a bunch of
people go like yeah man
I mean watch the old New Mutants just
under are they still coming out
theatrically they they claim August for
sure
that's what Disney said I ain't well you
know look I'm happy for him and stuff
finally they're getting out there but
like I read some article or glean her
glanced at some article rather where
they talked about why it couldn't go
right to streaming some contractual
thing that it has to go out theatrically
or something but you know I it's just
for that first few months back it's got
to be all [ __ ] you know big money
cards faces no whammies no whammies stop
we can't go back to the movies the way
we used to where it's like that is they
spent 50 million on this but didn't do
nothing but don't worry here's another
movie to see like it's these things
gotta earn in order for you know these
companies to be like alright yeah we'll
keep this up otherwise you got a Rican
sieve and you know somewhere there's a
lot of trying to figure out the movie
business I know there's there's probably
a really fascinating Field of Dreams
style indie film you could make about
like the the mom and pop / grandson
drive-in theater that was just on like
the [ __ ] shut up [ __ ] Cinderella
idea don't be giving away to grandpa kid
[ __ ] idea I mean you can't my grandpa
kid [ __ ] but the [ __ ] kid in the
grandpa different movie but like you
know I don't I don't want to make that
movie and I don't know how you could
make it because I don't know how much
people are gonna want to return to like
Cove Atlantia
yeah in the films anytime soon but just
that idea that I was holding on to a
business out of just like sheer gut by
the skin of my [ __ ] teeth and it just
so happened in the world shifted on its
axis and made it so that I had the one
thing that nobody else has which is a
way to go to the movies again dumber so
then why are you giving away [ __ ] like
that that's good you can ask the
majestic drive in the starlight oh we're
gonna talk after this I'm gonna tell you
the value of shut the [ __ ] up and keep
an eye on yourself
that's good that's another billion
dollar idea maybe we'll cut this one out
from five well those people will get to
see it there's someone's writing your
script right now to like [ __ ] that's
a good idea
me and my grandpa these people live will
be like the people who are in the book
where it's like listen we're cutting
this into podcast but we all here can
talk about this [ __ ] we can't tell
everybody else so you guys such a good
idea
alright I'll add it to the pile of
things I'll never have time to write
crapping out gold and thrown it away
like you're the Golden Goose
yeah Wow yeah all right for the Batmen
news the hat trick is complete the bat
trick is complete ladies and gentlemen
stop throwing your hats or your bats on
the ice what if there was four what
would you call the fourth Gordie Howe
hat trick because that's where you know
that's three Gordie Howe hat trick is a
goal and assist in a fight ooh that's
nice yeah but nobody has there's no
fourth no my dad no it's just like wow
he's good mmm it goes from I go my god
it's a [ __ ] celebration to like hey
did it again
there must be a double hat-trick like if
you get six goals Wow
yeah I mean cuz in basketball that's
called a triple-double it's if you have
three if you have points rebounds and
assists three stats all in double
figures that's a lot of math you saw my
face go like like what hold Stiles like
that meme of that lady who's like this
and they put math figures around or Jif
if you will or gif gif my bad yeah it's
always gonna be jiff to me yeah but it's
it's graphic it's gif isn't it yeah [ __ ]
that yeah all right what other stories
we got [ __ ] what's gonna top what we
talked about so far I got two left
oh one of them is more Mandalorian
casting news because it seems that even
though the season is shot and in the
bank they're just like how about this
now let me tell you something this is my
theory on why we're hearing so much
about the Mandalorian cuz remember you
know going into [ __ ] season one
nobody knew [ __ ] and you know suddenly
surprise baby oh - the biggest thing
ever
we're hearing a lot going into season
two you're making all the toys I mean I
got it up front like you ready buy that
a souca figure the day she airs but I
think it might mean that they have a
[ __ ] ton of amazing [ __ ] that we're not
hearing about if like these cats are
super [ __ ] tight and secretive mm-hmm
if we're hearing about the [ __ ] we're
hearing about like Boba Fett's in it and
so gitanos in it and [ __ ] this was it
Katie [ __ ] sad man is in it if we're
hearing that [ __ ] like maybe it's even
like you know oh you think that's it
like Darth Vader's in it knows like
maybe you know Luke Skywalker's in a
world where he was like recently he's
like nah I'm officially done I'm done
I'm done I'm done that morning also very
mirthful and [ __ ] child like Wonder
puckish even so I could see some world
where and he said very nice things about
that show so I'm just saying they're
like if we know about this [ __ ] they
must be like hiding the dark saber of it
all dude which they even showed us know
what I had all think million dollar idea
about to crap more gold
I wasn't cuz there's nothing I think I
mean I got the time lines crossed but I
was like what if Mark Hamill is playing
obi-wan Kenobi he's dead though I know
that's why I got my time lines crossed
Oh that'd be cool but it's not that
that's not gonna happen but yeah but
they're doing an obi-wan Kenobi series
yes and there is conjecture that ahsoka
who is appearing on Mandalorian for what
sounds like one Episode now is then
gonna pop up in that show which make a
lot of [ __ ] sense because they knew
each other from
Clone Wars yep so Dave Filoni
might like it she's coming in in a big
bad way she's come in focused time is
now he's gonna appear in everything man
this and she gets her own show you think
so I mean yeah I mean if rosarian wants
to do it which they would have to have
cleared it with she's a worker she loves
to work she doesn't run away after the
first season of a show man oh man like
that I saw that that was a cool idea
like the idea of like whoa she's gonna
be on the obi-wan Kenobi show it's like
yeah now look I was watching it anyway
now I'll watch it twice yes and I'll
tell others about
but so speaking of the mandalorian and
casting yeah Timothy Olyphant all a
fantastic all a fantastic another guy oh
yeah he's uh he he has joined there's
like he's joining the cast for season
two he's doing ready he's done let's say
who he's playing um they haven't said he
was playing although they there was
conjecture that he's playing some sort
of gunslinger which in my head
made me go to like CAD Bane who was a
character from the from both Clone Wars
he was like this sort of [ __ ] he was
there Han Solo for a little bit and sort
of the man with no name they were going
for the Clint Eastwood stuff but
according to Omega level dotnet I'm
citing them in case it's all [ __ ]
okay my [ __ ] there [ __ ] yeah all
the fonts film scenes wearing Boba
Fett's Mandalorian armor for the
upcoming second season of the
Mandalorian that might sound confusing
because early this month
Tamura Morrison who originated role of
Jango Fett is coming back as Boba Fett
but if Morrison is playing Boba Fett
then Timothy Olyphant is playing an
enigmatic character named Bob Vance
introduced in Chuck woundings aftermath
book series there's a whole list of the
reasons why that could be that it could
be the king goodness away they said that
Timothy Olyphant was wearing Boba Fett's
outfit at one point yes
maybe maybe it's a story of a guy who's
like I'm Boba Fett and then he's like
I'm really boba it's the I recovered the
armor from the Sarlacc pit and now I'm
wearing it the two Boba's the two boba
and when the other guy is like flashback
ii boba stuff hmm and not like in the
present everyone assumes oh my god they
brought him that means that Boba Fett
got out of the Sarlacc bet and Dave
Filoni would never counter anything
George Lucas has ever done without his
express permission so could be that
maybe the story is and again this is all
conjecture as much conjecture as the
Omega one story or whatever could be
that it's a guy who gets the armor and
is going around and he's got a you know
[ __ ] like you gotta track this guy
down he says he's one of us but he is
not that is not the way or whatever and
it turns out it was a guy who just
strapped on the armor that'd be pretty
dope story
he does then you leave continuity alone
you do you know he's still in the
Sarlacc pit maybe yo yeah I do like the
idea of like Boba Fett wants his [ __ ]
armor back and it's going to lead him up
against [ __ ] Raylan Givens that's a
story - I hadn't even thought about that
give me one like that it's the way it is
the way the man oh man
like we know so much about season two
and yet nothing at the same time and my
feeling is because we know a lot there's
so much more that like exciting [ __ ]
baby Yoda level [ __ ] coming like baby
bosque yeah it's a bee ig-88 or
something like that it's very it's
really smart from a PR perspective
because it's if I give you enough shiny
things you won't look for the other
thing yes you know pay no attention to
the man behind that curtain it reminds
me of when when Marvel just came out and
said oh yeah Ben Kingsley's playing the
Mandarin and we were like oh that's
[ __ ] cool pancakes is the Mandarin
amazing and so we don't for a second
look any deeper into what that is
because that seems to make sense right
and so then when you get to the middle
of the Iron Man 3 and you get that
awesome twist I'm not gonna spoil it
just in case you like [ __ ] you
were hiding in plain sight now and I
didn't even see it coming I was a good
kid you answered the question that you
knew I wanted to have answered and now
they get to do the Mandarin again mm-hmm
which is pretty amazing yeah all right
well that's [ __ ] hot news is that it
one last thing here it is the last news
Tuesday folks it is it is about Star
Wars and it's about publicity fella
named Charlie Lippincott who was the
very first the original Star Wars
publicist passed away oh my god you're
kidding me this was this jaw dudes job
to sell this movie to people who were
like Star Trek no no no no our wars
yeah he joined the Star Wars galaxy in
1975 as Lucas Films VP of advertising
publicity promotion and merchandising
Wow and to publicize Lucas's
then-unknown property he went outside
and all the practices at the time
teaming with Marvel Comics for a series
it came out ahead of the release or
organizing partnerships with the Richard
Pryor show and Donny Marie Show
and he is responsible for the holiday
special get outta here he was the one
who teamed up with CBS for the 1978
special all to keep it in public
consciousness until the next movie came
out and he was the one who took it to
Comic Con for the first time in 1976
what's his name
Charlie Lippincott how and what happened
did he stay with Lucasfilm um he would
eventually leave Lucasfilm I think he
then went to Fox and he helped to launch
alien and [ __ ] was the other one
hold on Oh Flash Gordon Wow oh I think I
got this we did Star Wars this guy I'm
your alien guy and even before Star Wars
he did Westworld he did oh [ __ ] Michael
Michael Crichton's because he was there
John regard he was a genre guy lever guy
you know these geeks and nerds don't you
you know how this works
but yeah and Lucasfilm Lucas George
Lucas in a statement said Charlie was
one of the founding pillars of the Star
Wars films and phenomenon he began in
earnest the concept of licensing motion
pictures at a time when the only other
company doing so was Disney Charlie was
the one who said early on we can make
this work and was the first person to
develop Star Wars licensing and engage
with the fans get insights into
marketing and public relations that were
truly unparalleled
wow man and that's a guy unsung hero
I've been following this ship my whole
life that's first time I ever heard that
dude's name probably yeah like I
remembered I did a panel at comic-con
the last comic-con that we had in San
Diego which was kind of all about how
the press began to deal with comic-con
in the 70s 80s and 90s and I remember
guys like Jeff Walker and Craig Miller
who had been part of that whole you know
spirit back in the day always talking
about Charles Lippincott and how he was
the guy who ya know we should go to
comic-con I think there's something here
like yeah I think I think you know if we
do these comic books maybe we'll
introduce an audience who would like
this stuff beforehand so they can
already be very interested in it and
visionary visionary it's and he was
doing a thing before anybody else did a
thing and we still live in that thing
very much so when the mandalorian is
deciding how very judiciously
to Chum the waters with casting
announcements and everything and it's
all it all traces back to oh Lippincott
it's
the PlayBook that that dude first
created I'm telling you if Disney Plus
skips making a Star Wars Christmas
special this year missed opportunity
Star Wars Christmas special 2020
Mandalorian Christmas special come on
let's go to the volume everybody we can
get this done that's all the news that's
all the news Martin Barnard and brought
you [ __ ] news you wanted news he
brought your news man give it up for
mark you have the news news and views uh
JC let's put the JC cam on and check in
on our good friend JC we got some
questions I've got some questions
what how's the show reaction been good
people love Ben what's not to love
everyone loves when Batman shows chap
blew up there yeah we more people I'm
sure they're like more Ben Affleck one
of those it or both of those guys should
quit it let's just have Ben Affleck
telling us these things
it's just Batman Batman we're calling
this yeah Batman on fat man yeah he just
calls Batman what you got some queries
for us uh yeah Adam go Vaizey
asks what if you wrote a Keanu Reeves
vehicle since everybody wants to what
would your pitch be funny you should ask
if I was writing a Keanu Reeves vehicle
mm can I be old new doesn't have to be
something that create that could be bad
there's yeah I put him in buckaroo
banzai
that's what I would you know - good idea
mazing idea guys somebody should try
that what about you I would put him in
Highlander
oh there could be only one in the only
one he could be a Christopher Lambert
he's like functionally immortal as far
as we can chance true Little Buddha
still and yes definitely has a Zen way
of attacking the world and cutting its
head off to steal his power brilliant
cause I just made me want to watch that
movie again the Kurgan the kind of guy
who can be only one
it's better to burn out and fade away
with the top-of-the-line agos listen
what I have to say or something like I
have something to say he's talking
another ladies I have something to say
it's better to burn out than fade away
oh I was doing [ __ ] karate in the
middle oh my god I remember seeing that
movie like years and years ago cuz it
didn't you know as a sleeper mm-hmm it
was a video hit the video hit that's
what I found and I was like this thorn
EMI HBO release yeah on video and like
being like why didn't it's got James
Bond did it how did my year and it was
one of those movies like shout out to
critics I know like in the past I've
always been like [ __ ] critics but
like Roger Ebert and Cisco Cisco and
Ebert taught me about Highlander really
yeah it was one of theirs and I think I
was like I'm trying to find this moving
[ __ ] but they would do so like that's
how I learned the term sleeper mmm like
they were the first ones like this movie
is a sleeper and you know which means
everyone slept on nobody's watch it but
they were the ones that turn me on a
Highlander they turn me on a buckaroo
banzai I think as well I think they did
a review where I was like holy [ __ ] yeah
I loved Highlander and I remember having
such like I must have seen it at 13 14
15 years old and I wanted I wanted
Russell Mulcahy I wanted Conor McLeod's
apartment so badly
you remember that like beautiful like
Greenwich Village loft with like it had
an elevator that came in it's like a
chunky look like Hanks his apartment a
big but we are without the toys but like
if you also had like in [ __ ] Queen
inside me blood of cake
no man can be my equal
take me dude literally a Spanish song of
the internet I am immortal
I have inside me blood of kings Prince
of the universe I like the Muppets man
oh man it's uh yeah that's like I might
go watch that tonight
it's cuts pull deep cuts poke but I
would I would never his lady gets old
yeah and that is his young Scottish lady
yeah yeah she no longer Heather Heather
and he doesn't age and she gets the old
I remember I was a kid I was like that
was the first time I'd been introduced
to that concept right cuz he mortality
just sounds [ __ ] awesome
when you're like 12 and also when I was
a kid immortality was like Jesus is
immortal and he saved our souls that's
immortal yeah I went for them when I saw
the Highlander I'm like this guy's
better than Jesus Jesus ain't cutting
anyone's head off in the Bible except
John the Baptist this guy's cutting
heads off left and right because they're
gonna be only one mana Kurgan what if
Jesus hung up with James Bond
the Christ lander I love this Sean
Connery is playing a Spaniard my name is
Juan Sanchez Villalobos Ramirez the
third this work sure some things here
don't react well to bullets Highlander
what out what's our second question
evening a major role wants to know if
you could host a game show pastor
present what would it be
game show a game show pastor present Oh
[ __ ] match game cuz I'd love to be
like John showed Mary his big fat black
and then like Charles Nelson Reilly and
Brett Somers or [ __ ] mmm casual
repartee sexual repartee that a young
keV couldn't quite understand Turner's
grandma
like what's a [ __ ] gram they didn't
say that but something like NBC was
risky in 1874 [ __ ] I could see doing
match game wait what does now involve
and do that now alright I'm not that one
cuz it's obviously being done what else
did I like oh god what was the name of
the [ __ ] game
treasure treasure hunt
do you remember treasure huh I don't
then wink Martindale hosted it no and
who was it I forget the name of the host
but it was like a series of boxes these
gorgeous boxes like filled this room and
then you answered a question and then
you got to go pick the BAA any box and
the box was cool enough a [ __ ] what was
in it as a kid I was like I'd love one
of them boxes I just I just wanted one
day they invented storage shops where
you could buy boxes but it was called
treasure hunt you pick a box and then
open it and then it would be like 100
dollars or you know a trip to Jamaica or
some such [ __ ] not very memorable
I wouldn't host that either cuz really
the boxes upstage you yeah I mean
they're the stars of the show and I'm
sure they were wrapped like presents
they were literally see not the Whammy
show because the whammies that start at
show family feud they're doing now [ __ ]
who legends of game show legends of the
Hidden Temple
oh [ __ ] you all I got it okay got it all
right I want to be the host of Starrcade
remember that [ __ ] show Oh video
games on the show mm-hmm feels like a
1982 jam like we've got a ColecoVision
for you guys that's that's what they
would win but they were playing like
[ __ ] you know zaxxon and [ __ ] like
that but it was such a [ __ ] you know
then again that doesn't really give you
a chance to shine you can't be funny and
[ __ ] because the people playing the
games are all intense and [ __ ] like that
no I still I'd do it star I'd do it they
call star what about you I'm torn so I'm
gonna just do both battle of the Network
Stars oh I feel like damn it what
oh god that makes me mad Jackie on your
show I mean there's always two hosts
right there's always like the two dudes
in the booth yeah you know like Fran
Tarkenton I'm pretty sure is gonna take
this one yes oh my god go Jay Simpson
don't run away with it we could be the
two people who would be the been at work
stars nowadays the ones that you could
get well I mean the they got everybody I
think you would probably have to do it
like one network I don't think you'd get
competing networks like they used to be
able to like you couldn't get like ABC
and CBS to fight each other why not
because why isn't that weird that ABC
and CBS would fight each other on NBC
that's what you couldn't get done that's
crazy yeah I think you could do it like
I would like to catch up this is us to
like go against the cast of whatever
Chicago PD like that you could do which
would still be kind of fun but it's more
like you know a family feud where it's
like it's the [ __ ] family from Modern
Family and it's the [ __ ] family from
another sitcom yeah what if it was like
battle of the [ __ ] network streamers
many links versus Hulu Plus like do I
get the Avengers not but not the actors
that played those characters the
characters yes so we actually have Thor
hello Thor and they put a budget beyond
these names if it's not live it's like
film with CG and [ __ ] like that I mean
if you could really we just want Secret
Wars is what Marx literally I want like
contest of Champions like I want good
one Marvel vs. DC [ __ ] how can we do
that what was the other one you said to
black jeopardy I will take hell now last
week remember there were two things that
you didn't know and you knew something
very white so I don't know if they're
gonna let you be the host of GLAAD
jeopardy and I didn't know leticia right
name is now burned into my memory I will
never feel that again the only other
time you'll ever forget her name is when
you finally meet her in real life and
you'd be like Judy it just went away
no I you're not sure II oh my god I hear
it is just taking my car back
I'll take home that what a great answer
he had my answer suck but that was great
[ __ ] battle of network says what a
great poll such good memories I think in
my head and heart I feel warm about it
but like I can't really point C on to
any single moment like do you remember
when Henry Winkler beat the [ __ ] grant
that was so weird
beat up an old guy it's one thing to see
a young guy wouldn't let him get up his
foot on his neck
it was cornerman Kelly did I feel like
if you're gonna go home and watch
Highlander I'm gonna go like scour
YouTube for old battles of the Network
Stars good pull worth it I wonder who
has the rights to those I just feel like
NBC did that [ __ ] yeah [ __ ] alike it's
the Merv Griffin company or somebody
like that
you're so right it's like they wouldn't
want it like I'm not gonna go [ __ ]
compete against ya well do our own show
alright man you know what else I mean
it's cartoon and it's not really a game
show but Wacky Races well you know life
Wacky Races or just animated Wacky Races
you wanting them to go anywhere they
just animate you in a booth just I'm
just saying point good point like real
life Wacky Races like now that we got
things like HBO max where they'll spend
like 30 40 million whatever to finish
the Justice League movie maybe they'll
put some real HBO Warner Brothers Warner
Bros owns all the hanna-barbera
characters maybe they do a live-action
[ __ ] Wacky Races because for the
three of us that remember that show
that'd be thrilling to see although you
could also do it on Disney Plus because
you've never Simpsons you got the Disney
characters oh my god you could have you
can have them yeah you can now yes you
can have Bart Simpson racing the alien
from aliens you can't have anything
versus Mickey meds
versus Scully and Mulder versus oh my
god we're onto something versus
spider-man Disney Plus call us we got a
thing yeah it's gonna be crazy to get a
[ __ ] you got the property we got the
pitch for it we don't have the rights to
any of it we really want you to pay us
to do it we just want to see a bunch of
character mashups third one and final
question of the evening JC Matt will
post is curious since ex Snyder is
getting a second chance on his movies
it's very David Lynch man as firewalk
with deep cuts go ahead
since zach is getting a second chance at
his movie what director do you think
should get a second chance at their
movie his choice Fincher and alien 301
hey what a great question be what a
great suggestion as well okay we're
playing this [ __ ] game now okay Kevin
Smith all of them one more Trent let me
see hmm you got one I'm circling one I'm
trying to find a better one oh all right
here off the top of my head not my deep
like Oh in my heart I've always wanted
this Steven Spielberg 1941 ooh just
because like that is a fantastic [ __ ]
film but it ran into problems it is
Steven Spielberg's probably you know the
the I wouldn't ever call it a failure
but the one that did not pop like a
Spielberg movie right so a second bite
at that Apple okay all right I'm gonna
go David Lynch and doom show that is
genius
yes have you ever seen the Alan Smithee
cut yeah like four hours recognize like
an hour of talking up top pretty much it
was like wrong
we didn't shoot this never gonna shoot
this I just have virginia madsen talk
over some series of drawings later oh my
god how true and to turn it into like a
multi-part series that's opposed to one
movie yeah II ain't never they're never
gonna give him oh no no no no no they
got a brand new doom coming man peanu oh
boy what a great poll that is such a
good idea I can't even
there's no point that's that is the top
that is top five answers are on the
board here's the question and [ __ ]
that with big David Lynch's dunno G
audience see family feud so they said
Bing Victor Garber as fade arouse Victor
Garber ladies and gentlemen what a great
poll that was fantastic
that's our three questions good times
I'm so glad we had this time together
how awesome we got to hang out and how
awesome that Batman himself swung in I
know it's just piped in from the Batcave
more of that right yeah more more movie
stars so that bar has been raised
it's crazy what a buck good movie star
will do for the show we're like look at
that that's action value
we didn't never got him in the bar but
from the safety of his own home what is
what's vertical and what's horizontal
horizontal like landscape and portrait
so is this horizontal that's horizontal
and this is vertical yes so it goes do
you want a horizontal horizontal
horizontal horizontal vertical and I was
like who's such a director I'll take it
horizontal and he gave it to me and then
I was like I guess I don't know what
horizontal but thank God he gave us the
full-body shot cuz he looks he looks
good he looks ready to [ __ ] get in
the suit he looks like he got that call
like a month ago good night in November
thank you to Ben Affleck for popping in
indeed on fat man beyond the to almost
meet you next
Marketing do you enjoy yourselves
tonight ladies German have you been to
entertained this more this remember that
movie Remember The Joker did this once
it's 20 years old gladiator he's
[ __ ] me
if he came on mm could you imagine your
wife you think you're like I you know I
got hits in every decade like major hits
like that movie was cut out who's in
every area code and he played the bad
guy in that movie yeah Commodus and then
he [ __ ] plays the bad guy in hooker
mm-hmm he's good at that
he's a but he's a good guy I'm really
sweet guy I'm terribly Thaxton he just
comes across that way mmm he plays it
that way he does um there it is folks we
started by talking about Batman we
finished by talking about the Joker and
that makes sense for a show called fat
man beyond what a wonderful show ladies
a good time if I did say so mad a
himself but we got no show without the
man standing over there man give it up
for mr. mark barnard n' you everybody
and we got no place to do this show
we're not for JC and the scum and
villainy Cantina there he is he gave
himself a [ __ ] close-up and [ __ ] like
a boss he's like just in case they don't
know JC is click look at me
um are you still buying that boss card
cards
give me your close-up and do a little
selling we we sold out this week but we
should have more in Monday or Tuesday
[ __ ] these things are heavy man like
[ __ ] it's a gift certificate right
then you use here yes super hard to keep
in your wallet you can't slip it in your
wall and [ __ ] and if you put it in your
pants it pulls your pants down and like
nowadays nobody's weren't belts you say
that [ __ ] as an occupational hazard
it's like having a Coppertone dog
hanging at the your ass is our buddy
scarce these seventies references well
the matter can they so you're getting
best cars what do you call them scar
inspired yes not actual screen used yeah
no heavy-metal cards calm heavy metal
heavy metal but their actual it's actual
edge laser etched aluminum their sweet I
saw him in real life and yeah two week
about measurement stubs and wait it's
good for one user every time you come in
the bar you can use it you're good they
have a hundred and fifty dollars on them
so you can come in and just reuse it
could you keep reloading I don't know
because we haven't been open like you're
describing a world I dream about where
people come in every day because I'm
open and bending when we get to use one
of these you're gonna see some serious
[ __ ]
oh my could you imagine everyone
slapping him there you're gonna shatter
this counter when everybody comes in
they're like here's my steel and it's
gonna crack the counter chip you can go
to where can they go get a gift
certificate scum and villainy cantina
dot-com and click on the shop link up at
the top that's right rock on we will be
back next week hopefully with more news
you got anything going on you want to
send them to one last time heads plague
nerd logs to go and see like some of
your favorite genre actors doing some of
your favorite genre speeches all for
charity and hero initiative
maybe we sold out those last two slots
maybe we didn't we haven't been able to
check after a show like this if those
slots aren't just sold out it is gonna
be six people who like so let's talk
about a static cut yo you had some
things to say I want you to explain
yourself and all nice my money to do
this
hero initiative that work is where you
can find the that and there's a bunch of
other auctions up there probably still
with other folks that you might love and
no gems don't got wonderful the Lord's
work over there the heroes here inertia
and I think they're gonna keep doing
them for a while because like you know
even once we get out of you know the
cocodes own and we get to reopen and we
get to re-engage with our loved ones and
in the traditional god intended way
there are still lots of people who need
help and lots of old veterans of comic
books and and and the stuff that you
love who need assistance so this isn't
going away anytime soon so yeah
believe more beautiful thing right there
there and what's the nurdle logs address
the plague nurdle logs dot-com go check
it out check that it is amazing I'm
gonna add mine this week mm-hmm so let's
see if I can cry let's see what kind of
actor I am genre go to your place Kevin
yeah I already picked out where I'm
gonna shoot it and everything I got one
of them ring light stick my camera so
[ __ ] fancy yeah I am in [ __ ] I'm
Trisha helpful got nothing on me you
know I will say she's got like a foot on
you she does beyond that that and she's
tall she's beautiful she's talented he's
got everything out of me woman
everything about her is better than me I
know that's who you really love if Mark
can host this show it's just Tricia
Helfer anybody would rot drive over my
neck like one of those movies real like
I thought they were friends like a mob
movie and [ __ ] he'd put he's groats me
and [ __ ] I'd drop be on the bar
ginger ale for pops up believe the weed
take the cannoli if you're looking for
me kids you can find me over at that
Kevin Smith Club calm and man shy of
that that ladies and gentlemen is fat
man beyond for this week I'm Kevin Smith
I'm mark barnard tune in next week more
movie stars more movie stars that's
gonna be our model mms more movie stuff
who do you got this week not a movie
star everyone who's ever been in a Kevin
Smith movie tune in next week same fad
time same fat channel SModcast calm or
youtube.com slash Kevin Smith Snider car
[Music]